Wow.
Oh, wow. It's been so long. Holy cow, baby.
Oh, my gosh. How's life? I
was
too. I had to leave. I thought I had to get my cup of...
They did a great job, man.
That was the only part I could see. I'd be like...
A union? I've just had union HPR, which
is technically a
CS. Tim,
do
you
guys
remember each other after we got off?
Tim was a Harvard student. He was a...
Hi, Kelly.
Wow. Holy cow.
She's a big girl
now.
She's
a mom.
You
were at Elon for like-
I think I need to have a slide to see it.
I can't see it, but I don't want to move to his slide.
I think I need to get...
Yeah, where is he?
I don't want to advance to his slide.
Come up.
Well, let me close out.
Okay.
Yeah. I should have. It would've been nice if
I'd memorized it. Sabrina Spencer, how are you? Nice to see you.
Congratulations.
I
think it's on a fixed slide, so I cannot see the mouse.
Car, respectful.
Should I ask them about the...
Excuse me. Do you
think the mouse is working? Because I want to check.
Oh, thanks.
Because I don't see the mouse or the arrow.
It might be rotated off right now.
Oh, really?
So, I mean, yeah. Just like a week ago, it fell off the table.
Let me talk with the tech at the table.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I have enough experience to know that there are always problems.
Are we
not
able to advance?
We don't see the mouse.
I think we're on a holding slide right now.
But that's how we want to be sure.
Are we on a holding slide? Are we on a holding slide?
Yes.
Okay, I think we need to get started, so we need to just go ahead and go to
presentation.
Yeah, it's there.
Mm-hmm.
It's there. Can I just advance one to see? Yeah, it does.
I don't know how to do that.
To make sure Dr. Lattai, what he was commissioned is going to make
sense.
Do you want to come up?
What do you think? I think it's easier, right? In the middle seat.
And then I have about maybe two minutes of introduction for you.
Oh, sure. Okay.
We're good to go?
Yeah. Okay.
Good afternoon.
I am Lillian Siu, and as of a few minutes ago, the immediate past
president of the AACR.
On this panel, as you can see, we have the current president, Dr.
Keith Flaherty, and our NCI director, Dr. Anthony Lattai.
I'll introduce Dr. Lattai in a minute, but I would like to explain the format of
today's session, which is the NCI Director's Address.
We will have Dr. Lattai give us a brief presentation, and then
we will go straight into the fireside chat, at which point, we
will take questions, of course, from all of you.
We would suggest that you scan the QR code now so that in case you have questions
through his presentation, you can enter that into the
Slido or the web, and we will take that during the
fireside chat. There will be no microphone set up, so everything will be
through the QR code to enter your questions.
So with that, allow me to introduce Dr. Lattai.
It is really my great honor to introduce a leader whose scientific
insight and commitment to patients reflect the very best of our cancer
research community. Dr. Anthony Lattai was sworn in as the
18th director of the National Cancer Institute last September.
He brings to his role more than two decades of distinguished service at the
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and Harvard Medical School, where he built an
internationally recognized program as a physician-scientist
dedicated to understanding how cancer cells survive and how these
processes can be targeted therapeutically.
As both a practicing oncologist and laboratory
investigator, Dr. Lattai has devoted his career to advancing our
understanding of apoptotic pathways and mitochondrial
priming. His work has expanded the field's understanding of therapeutic
response and resistance and has informed more precise,
biology-driven approaches to treatment that are improving patient
care. He is widely respected for his scientific rigor,
his commitment to collaboration, and his dedication to mentoring the
next generation of investigators.
Throughout his career, he has championed the importance of translating
discovery into meaningful benefit for our
patients. Dr. Lattai assumes leadership of the
NCI at a time when cancer research continues to be
recognized as a national priority.
Decades of sustained bipartisan federal investment in the
NIH and NCI have driven extraordinary progress.
The US cancer death rate has declined by 34% since
1991, representing millions of lives saved.
The commitment is strongly supported by the American public.In
a national survey conducted by the AACR last fall,
83% of Americans expressed support for increasing
federal funding for cancer research.
Nearly two in three voters reported a high level of confidence
in the NCI. Public trust in cancer research remains
broad and bipartisan.
At the center of that trust stands the NCI and its director.
NCI is the driving force behind the
foundational science that enables earlier detection,
more precise therapies, and better outcomes for our patients.
It supports researchers in every state and
sustains our nation's global leadership in biomedical
innovation. Dr. Lotai's experience at the bench
and at the bedside and in leadership uniquely prepares him for this
responsibility. We're deeply grateful for his willingness to
serve and for the steady, thoughtful leadership, and
stewardship that he brings to this critical role. Dr.
Lotai, we are really honored to have you here at the AACR annual
meeting, and we appreciate the opportunity to hear from you today about
how we can support your priorities and work together
effectively and productively with you and your colleagues at the
NCI to prevent the major increases in cancer
incidence and mortality that are projected over the next couple
of decades. Please join me in welcoming to the podium the
director of the National Cancer Institute, Dr. Tony Lotai.
All right. Let me just make sure I get this clipped on properly.
In the pocket.
Thank you, Dr. Su, for your introduction, and thank you, AACR, for welcoming me.
While I have attended this meeting my entire career, I would guess over
20 times,
having the opportunity to do so in the capacity of NCI director is an honor I never
imagined, and I can say people have never been friendlier to
me.
Today, I'm going to talk about
sort of the momentum and
milestones in cancer research. I'll talk a little bit about
navigating the evolving landscape of policies related to funding, and I hope I can
clear up some confusion, and I think misconceptions on this
topic. And I'll also discuss my vision and priorities for the NCI.
I'm thrilled to stand before you and share the progress we've made against
cancer. All of you
are responsible for that progress, from early-stage investigators, to
foundational scientists, to clinicians testing new therapies, to industry
partners scaling and delivering these therapies, and to patient
advocates reminding us why this work matters.
None of that progress would be possible without precision, partnership, and
purpose, a theme AACR has thoughtfully woven into this year's
program. It's truly incredible to see the cutting-edge science underway,
the cross-sector collaborations making it all possible,
and the devotion and purpose shared by individuals in this community.
That purpose is driving us to do even better, but we still have work to do.
I want to start by returning to the initiative I mentioned in the opening
ceremony called Your NCI.
As I said then, AACR brings together the entire cancer research
continuum.
I shared one example of an important breakthrough from the last quarter-century and
showed how NCI was at the core of cancer research there.
That is Your NCI, sustained
public investment translating into discovery, innovation,
and better outcomes for patients.
All of us here share a common goal: to reduce suffering from cancer.
We've made enormous progress to the goal in the last 35
years.
As you heard in Dr. Su's spoiler, cancers are down
33% since 1991.
We have clear evidence that better screening and prevention,
along with lower smoking rates, have contributed to this decrease.
Over five million people are alive today who otherwise would have been claimed by
cancer without these preventative and therapeutic interventions.
We've also seen benefit from better treatments.
Chronic myeloid leukemia, multiple myeloma, melanoma,
HER2 positive breast cancer, and lung cancer have gone from having dismal
prognoses to being manageable conditions, giving people more time
with their families and loved ones, more time to contribute to their communities
and to their work.
While enormous progress has been made, we also have a long way to go,
particularly in key areas such as early onset cancers,
recurrence and treatment resistance, and reducing disparities in access to
prevention. I just had lunch across the table from a lady who was
diagnosed with colorectal cancer at the age of 17.
That was really unheard of decades ago.
I want to make it absolutely clear, however, NCI is up to the challenge.
I also want to acknowledge that for many of you,
the past year has felt very turbulent.
I want to tell you one thing very clearly, the NCI is
stable,
our mission remains unchanged, and funding is
strong.
We are here as your partners in creating a future where cancer is no longer a
word people fear.
And that future is within reach because we now understand better, we move
faster, and we reach further than ever before.
I also know there's understandable confusion about charting the course
ahead. We've seen policy shifts, particularly in funding structure,
that have raised questions about the effectiveness of the federal research
enterprise.Let me start with some
budgetary facts.
Although the requirements for multi-year funding in fiscal year 2025
did affect our ability to provide the same number of new grants,
we actually provided more dollars to extramural research in fiscal year
2025 than at any time in the history of the National Cancer
Institute. We continue to devote roughly three-quarters of our
budget to the extramural research community because you are the main source of
innovation in this country.
For fiscal year 2026, our staff is working around the clock to
review and approve grants.
Despite early delays, largely related to the government shutdown,
the pace of grant funding in fiscal year 2026 is accelerating.
Roughly 200 new competing grants and about 1,500
non-competing grants are already processed and paid out to the
cancer centers, universities, and medical centers around the country.
Clear evidence that funding is moving and the system is working.
I expect that in fiscal year 2026, we will fund
more extramural research, more new research project grants,
and more early-stage investigator awards than in fiscal year '25.
That is to say, I expect fiscal year 2026 to be another
record year of extramural funding for the NCI.
Here, I want to highlight NCI's final appropriation for fiscal year
'26. I want to remind you, the only budget that really counts is the
budget that is approved by Congress and signed by the President, and this
reflects those numbers.
This included an increase of $128 million to the NCI
budget and a total appropriation of about $7.3 billion.
This is our appropriation enacted by Congress and reflects that our
funding is strong and stable.
While I said the only budget that matters is the final approved budget, there are a
lot of budgets that float around Washington, and this is something I had to wrap my
head around a little bit. As you look at this, you can see there's five different
colors, five different kinds of bars.
The only one that really matters is the maroon one that's all the way on the right
for each of the annual groupings here.
An important point I want to make is that the President's
budget is a starting point, and then the legislature needs to opine, and then they
need to come together and come to an agreement.
I think we should be very gratified that the President's budget
for 2027 has started with a number that is flat compared
to last year's enacted budget and does not reflect a cut in the NCI,
despite the difficult fiscal environment we're in right now.
I think this reflects a vote of confidence by the entire government in the
mission and the execution of that mission by the National Cancer Institute.
We haven't changed our commitment to funding, but what has changed is how we
deliver that funding, but maybe not as much as you might think.
The NIH has adopted a new unified funding strategy.
At its core, this is about no longer using a strict pay line, a
numerical cutoff that determines what grants get funded.
We are now also considering additional factors like alignment with the
NIH mission, balance across our scientific portfolio,
and career stage, especially supporting early-stage investigators.
But let me be extremely clear about this.
Peer review and scientific merit remain the most
important factors in determining whether a grant is funded or not.
There simply is no longer a line in the sand like there used to be.
Now we use what we call Select Pay, and it's not brand new.
We always used to use Select Pay for about 15% of our portfolio,
but now we're using it in all our funding decisions.
Decisions are still driven by science, and the goal is to complement peer review
so that we can move and make more strategic decisions about how we invest now.
I've also heard concern about transparency and politicization, and I
want to address that directly.
Funding decisions at the NCI are driven by scientific expertise,
peer review, and our core mission to reduce the burden of cancer.
As director, I am part of that process, but these decisions are
grounded in science and informed by the judgment of experienced researchers and
program leadership.
I am the political appointee with final say over all NCI
grants, and that is consistent with how NCI has operated since the
passage of the National Cancer Act in 1971.
The second aspect of our funding approach is how we are using multi-year or upfront
funding. I know there's some uncertainty around this, so let me clarify how
it works. Foremost, we are maintaining a similar proportion of
multi-year funding as in the prior year.
A helpful way to think about multi-year funding is a simple analogy.
It's like the difference between financing a car and buying it outright.
Traditionally, we funded grants like financing a car.
We pay them one year at a time. With multi-year funding, for some grants, we
provide the full amount upfront, more like buying the car in cash.
An advantage we realize is then we are no longer on the hook for the out years,
years, say, two, three, four, and five in a five-year grant.
But I do not see enthusiasm in Congress for a continuing increase in
multi-year funding, and they do have a say in this.
Rest assured, though, no matter what the multi-year funding decisions are, we have
plans to execute the mission of the NCI.
Now, that changes how things look in terms of new award counts, but it doesn't
change how much research we're actually supporting.
I think a concept that might be helpful is to think in terms of science years.
When we fund a grant year by year, we're investing in one science year at a
time. When we fund a grant up front, we're investing in several years of science
all at once. And I want to emphasize, this is a managed approach, not a
wholesale shift.
Guidance from Congress for fiscal year 2026 is to maintain multi-year
funding at roughly the same proportion as fiscal year
'25.At the same time, NCI continues to support the
extramural community at a level of 5.5 billion a year.
The multi-year funding reflects about $480 million of that.
There are also important downstream effects.
We get more flexibility to support new ideas, and it provides greater
stability and continuity for investigators who are less exposed to the
uncertainties of annual continuing and resolutions and other disruptions.
Related to multi-year funding, we are also thinking about new ways to support
high-risk, high-reward science.
One concept we're exploring is funding the first two years of a five-year project,
and then after an administrative review, deciding to continue based on what
we learn. This lets us support ideas that might not have been
funded under a traditional five-year model.
I think that many of us who've been on study sections have experienced or
encountered grants that look pretty good, have clever, innovative ideas,
but say, specific aim one might look a little risky, and it doesn't get a good
score on that basis. Those are the type of grants we want to, in some ways,
rescue so that we will fund the first two years and see if
specific aim two works out, and if it does, we can make a very rapid
administrative decision to fully fund that.
Another change you're seeing is how we communicate scientific priorities.
We're placing much more emphasis on NIH and NCI highlighted topics
and less on traditional NOFOs, Notices of Funding Opportunities.
Highlighted topics allow us to signal areas of opportunity without
constraining innovation. Instead of shaping your research to fit a
specific call, you can pursue ideas and align them
where you see the opportunity. We want to encourage
investigator-initiated science while still providing some guidance.
I also realize that there is some concern about the stance of the NCI and the
NIH on performing research on animals.
I would like to make clear that neither NIH nor NCI are
forbidding animal research.
When I reflect on my own career, I can say that the progress of my own laboratory
was greatly assisted at times by animal studies, and I understand that they can
be very valuable. At the same time, I think that for
ethical and for scientific reasons, it's essential that when we
perform animal studies, we're able to describe why these experiments are
necessary for the questions we want to answer.
In practical terms, NCI would like to see an explicit
justification for the necessity of animal studies when it's
proposed. This doesn't have to be long, a few sentences will do.
I would also strongly encourage you to include such a
justification like this even in the abstract, because
that is a part of the grant that's viewed by many people, including me.
However, I also think it's important that this is not just a workaround.
There is a changing current here associated with the new approach
methodologies or NAM program.
There's going to be more emphasis at NIH and the NCI to prioritize research
that is more directly relevant to human biology.
I think many of us who've worked with mice find them useful tools, but there are
limitations to how relevant they always are to the human condition.
The good news, though, is that advances in biological technology have made it
easier than ever to answer complex questions using human tissues.
I'm not sure the entire cancer community is even aware of these
advances. However, I urge you to remember that as scientists,
our job is to answer questions, and if human tissues can answer these
questions with greater reliability than animal tissues, we should try
very hard to include human tissues in our planning.
So when you step back, the broader picture, I hope, should be reassuring,
and if you agree, please spread the word.
NCI's mission is steady, our commitment to the research enterprise
is steady, and our focus remains on advancing the best science
on behalf of patients.
Our goal is to move forward in a way that gives investigators, institutions, and
staff confidence that NCI will no longer-- Sorry.
NCI will continue to support high-quality science with
consistency and purpose.
See, this is my first time around. Next time, I'll get that right.
If you're doing research, if you're participating in a trial, if you're helping
deliver a therapy, you're advocating for patients, you're part of
our community, you are part of the NCI.
This brings me to a question for all of you.
What will you, as part of this community, do to bring the breakthroughs of the next
quarter century? Where can you focus your efforts to make the cancer research
system stronger, faster, and more effective for people with cancer?
Let me challenge you to consider a few areas I believe are particularly important.
First, competitiveness. The United States is no longer the
world's only engine of biomedical innovation.
Other countries like China, Australia, New Zealand, and some in Europe, are
investing heavily and moving faster, particularly in early-stage clinical
trials. I am not the only one noticing this.
Other divisions at HHS have also been looking at this, and I expect NCI will help
with boosting early-phase trial efficiency.
We all know it takes too long in this country to move from a promising idea
to testing it in humans. Some barriers are, of course, necessary
to ensure safety and rigor. Others are simply inefficiencies that have
accumulated over time.
Fixing these will require coordination across biotech and pharma, the
FDA and regulatory bodies, cancer centers, practitioners, patient
advocates, and the NCI. I'm encouraged to see that all
of these parties that I've spoken to are supportive of making trials faster,
less expensive, and more efficient.
Many of you will be hearing from me and others at the NCI over the next year
in an effort to improve the speed and efficiency of the US clinical trial
apparatus. I urge you to embrace the opportunity for change in a
way that will benefit patients, clinical trialists, and the
entire biomedical ecosystem of the United States.
Another priority at the NCI that we continue to
embraceIs training the next generation of researchers.
I think about this not only as director of the NCI, but also
as the proud parent of an early-stage investigator.
I know they feel uncertain about this environment they're stepping into.
Institutions are also responding to broader uncertainty.
We see hiring delays, smaller startup packages, amid tighter
resource allocation. And in that environment, early investigators who have
smaller labs and shorter track records are often the most vulnerable.
I understand why that creates anxiety, and I want to take that
seriously.
I want to assure you that NCI is still committed to supporting ESIs
through our numerous training opportunities.
If we want the next breakthrough, we must invest in the people who will discover
it, and those are often early stage investigators pursuing bold,
new ideas.
I know the number of ESI R01s decreased in fiscal year
2025. However, NCI is planning and budgeting this year to
make more ESI awards in fiscal year '26 and return to the
levels that we were used to all throughout the 2020s.
Our support for ESIs comes in the form of structured pathways to independence
and extended support beyond an initial grant period.
Career stage is also considered in funding decisions to ensure
ESIs are not crowded out by more established applicants.
Among our many programs, we're also advancing a trans-NCI effort to help us
take a fresh look at how we train the next generation based on the real needs of
the community.
This system only works if new investigators are given the opportunity to lead
and if they believe this is a system worth committing their careers to.
If you are an early stage investigator, I urge you to
stay strong in your commitment. Despite the travails of the past year,
the overall NCI funding picture is strong and young cancer
researchers, and I think we often forget this, have never started
their careers with more powerful tools or more knowledge at their
disposal than there is today.
Another area I want to highlight, close to my heart, is functional
precision medicine. The idea is actually pretty simple.
If you want to know whether a drug will work on a patient's tumor,
take that living tumor tissue, expose it to the drug, and observe
what happens.
Instead of inferring whether a treatment will work based on genomics or model
systems, functional precision medicine lets us learn directly from the patient's
own biology in real time.
You can often test multiple drugs simultaneously and make informed choices about
what is most likely to work. This aligns with the broader NIH policy
to increase use of direct human-based systems.
To help move this forward, we've begun convening the community, first through a
workshop at the beginning of July.
Keep your eyes posted if you're interested.
Keep your eyes peeled for the posting, that is, to define how NCI can
support both intramural and extramural efforts in this space.
Functional precision medicine has numerous applications for
discovery, understanding biological
vulnerabilities we've previously not identified, as a companion
biomarker, and also as a tool for personalized treatment decisions,
especially for people who have run out of options.
I am confident this technology is more advanced and more feasible than
most people in the cancer research community realize.
I challenge you to think about how your work touches functional precision medicine.
What are ways that you can answer questions important to your research using
these exciting new technologies?
And finally, I want to come back to something fundamental, population
science, prevention, and access.
We've made enormous progress in reducing cancer mortality, and a
significant portion of that progress has come from prevention, especially
reducing tobacco use, as well as from early detection.
But those benefits are not reaching everyone equally.
There are still communities where access to screening and prevention programs is
limited.
That's why we are introducing an effort called the Prevention, Screening, and Early
Detection Initiative with the secretary's blessing
to bring evidence-based screening to the underserved parts of the country.
We'll start with counties in five states, and if it's successful, our vision is to
expand what we learn to enhance screening access and care
across the country.
We are currently convening coordination meetings with operational divisions across
the Department of Health and Human Services, and their contributions are going to
be absolutely essential to realizing this initiative and
implementing it.
My message to you is to think about who you're not seeing in your work.
Who is not participating in this trial?
Who is not showing up for their screening appointments?
Consider ways you can reach out to those people, because a breakthrough only
matters if it reaches the people who need it.
All of this is part of the same system,
the funding and policy that stewards taxpayer dollars, our priorities and
responsibilities as a public health agency, and your research,
innovation, and advocacy. It's a system and a community that
depends on precision, partnership, and purpose,
on smart investment and on collaboration.
This meeting is a unique opportunity to come together as a
community to work toward our shared goal of helping people live
longer, healthier lives.
I've been inspired by everyone I've met and listened to so far, and I look
forward to more opportunities to discuss, debate, and share
over the next day or so.
This community, all of you,
are extraordinarily strong and capable of turning ideas into real benefits
for people with cancer. We've seen it.
You are present at a uniquely leverageable time in cancer research, the
sort of time where committed individuals can have the most impact.
Thank you for your time, and I look forward to continuing the conversation with the
fireside chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Lattime.
Can you hear me? Is the mic on?
I can.
Can you turn the mic on?
There you go.
Perfect.
First of all, let me thank you for highlighting our meeting's theme,
Precision, Partnership, and Purpose, and thank you so
much for having this time. It means a lot to all of us for you
being with us today.
As you know,
between Keith and I, we have the privilege of continuing this conversation with
you. And I speak for our entire community that we're
eager to hear your perspectives on the path ahead.
So I'll start.
We are a community that have always believed in the power of working
together, and we're deeply grateful to have a partner
in you. So I'd like to start by asking you directly, and I think you've
already highlighted some of the areas you're interested in.
As you settle into your role as the NCI director, what are your
priorities for the institute? Maybe highlight a little bit more on what you've
talked about and more if you have. And what can this community...
How can we best support them?
Okay. I'll mention a couple in addition to what I've mentioned already.
I think another priority is communication.
I'm not sure, and I think you saw that in
what I tried to do in the opening session.
I am concerned that I don't think a lot of America understands what the National
Cancer Institute does or might think that it's sort of a building in Bethesda
alone, and they're not aware of how important the work of the
extramural community is or how central that is to the NCI.
You can see it in the numbers. Three-quarters of our budget is spent in the
extramural program. Most of the work based on that, that has come out of
the NCI has come from the extramural program.
So we want to highlight, we want patients to understand, not just patients, but
their families and people across the country.
We want them to understand that when they see an active,
exciting new drug advertised by a drug company during the Super Bowl,
that that started with an NCI grant.
Of course,
biotech and pharma are essential partners in making this happen.
The NCI is not going to make drugs and market them.
We need people to carry the football over the finish line, but we
need people to get it started, too, and that's what the NCI is.
We act, in some ways, almost as pre-angel investors in
the academic, largely, cancer community,
although we also provide SBIR grants to the early commercial
community as well. So I want to make that message more clear to the
American people and let them know what they are getting for their money, because I
think it's a fabulous product, and they get fabulous payoff from it, not
only in terms of reduced mortality, but actually in terms of economic growth as
well. I also want to highlight a program I didn't mention here, which is a
vaccine program. One of the things I want to test out a little bit more
is
trying to place some more significant bets on exciting new
technologies. One of these that came to my attention, and
just by pure coincidence, you would've seen it in the session that preceded us in
this room,
are cancer vaccines. These are therapeutic vaccines, not preventative
vaccines. These are given to people who already
have cancer, with the goal of either eradicating known tumor
or reducing the risk of a nearly inevitable relapse after, say, a
resection. What's exciting, I think, if you follow the literature in the
last few years, we're starting to see some very exciting signals in
some very hard-to-treat cancers,
where we're actually seeing, in cases where mortality is extremely high,
an apparent prevention of relapse and, in some cases, what looks like cure.
Many years out, there's still no evidence of tumor.
So in order to address that, we
convened a working group,
and that met before Christmas. And in, I think it was
early March, Cathy Wu presented the findings in the early roadmap of that committee
to the NCAB in a public session. I believe it's accessible online if you'd like
to see it. But the main idea is that we're going to fund
three different
clinical trials over the next three years that will give us some go, no-go signals
in the cancer vaccine field. We're going to stay out of the way of the trials that
are already being performed by pharmaceutical firms.
We want to do something that wouldn't otherwise be done.
But I think we can add a lot to the conversation and identify some interesting new
ways forward. I want to make it clear, although
this may have started as an NCI idea, it is not a purely NCI
project. We plan on contributing very significantly to this,
and the secretary has endorsed it even very recently in his comments.
However, it's going to be run by the FNIH, the Foundation for NIH,
because
this is going to be a public-private partnership.
They are great leaders of projects like this, and I very much
look forward to working with them.
So can you speak to how this community can support the initiatives that you have
outlined?
I'd say the scientific initiatives, you can sort of,
if something tickles your fancy and you like it, send in
applications along those lines. Now,
I want to be somewhat limited in
how the NCI guides the extramural community.
I think it would be foolish to regulate too much what new ideas are
exciting, and it's only going to be the minority of funds that will be directed
according to things that we come up with at the NCI or that I come up
with. We still depend, for the majority of innovation, on the extramural
community to use their brains to come up with cool
ideas, and there'd be no reason for us to want to subvert that.
However, if you see ideas that you're excited by, check out our highlighted topics,
check out our request for applications, and apply accordingly.
Cite those when you apply, and I think they're likely to gain more
interest.
Tony,
well, first off, I want to start by thanking you for taking this
job.You and I have known each other for quite a long time.
It's true.
We trained as residents together.
I ran away for a decade to Philadelphia, but then came back, and we've been under
the same comprehensive cancer center umbrella for almost 16 years before
you yourself ran away to take on this
mission. And,
having
watched you sort of settle into the role,
and clearly you've learned a lot about
how the process works of NCI, situated
in the executive branch, kind of communication with Congress.
I think the question I have
is one that I think a lot of people have about looking into the crystal ball
beyond just this next budgeting year's negotiation.
Basically, it'd be a two-part question.
One is sort of how do you
look at the outer years, two years, three years from now, and have confidence
that, kind of the investment conviction around that investment is
going to be maintained. But I guess as much as anything, I
recognize that you can't lobby Congress,
but we want to know how we can be more effective in
communicating.
Certainly, we, I think all as a community,
share your conviction, that you described at the opening session, that we need to
communicate directly to the public in a more effective way.
But we also want to be able to more effectively communicate to our legislators.
And so just kind of thinking about the high level of support
that the public seems to have for cancer research, ACR conducted a poll
in this past year.
83% of people
in that responded to that poll supported an increase
in public funding of cancer research.
One would think that that would translate to
very consistent support and even potential increases.
So I think, maybe bridging from the communication to the public part
to what we can do as a community to sort of strengthen our case to our legislators,
just be interested in your thoughts.
I'll reference the first part of your question, which is
regarding, I think, government and how I see stability going forward.
I really do see stability going forward.
I have had the opportunity to talk to the President, to the Secretary fairly
regularly, to legislators on both sides of the aisle in both houses
of Congress, and they just want us to cure cancer.
I can honestly say there's no one subjecting the NCI
to any other plan, any other priorities.
They want us to cure cancer, and they want us to do it as soon as possible.
And I think that's fine with me. The NCI
is not meddled with. There's no one forcing extra priorities
on us.
I think we're in a very privileged situation because
everyone's on our side. Someone
who went before me, Ned Sharpless, before I took this job, told me that it's the
best job in government because nobody hates you.
And it's true.
You wouldn't know, I've told other people this.
When I go into a
legislative, of course, I get prepped, but if I hadn't been prepped by my staff, I
wouldn't know the party of the person I'm talking to based on the content of our
discussion.
Mm-hmm.
It's always very positive. People want to support cancer research.
I think it's a very genuine feeling.
I could say, even if they were completely cynical,
they would support cancer research because it's politically the right thing to do
as well.
Mm-hmm.
It's so overwhelmingly popular to support cancer research.
And I hear the same thing from the executive branch.
I've actually been very impressed, maybe this will be reassuring to you, is that
at HHS and throughout the NCI and the NIH,
people just want to make things work, and they want to make
things work well for the sake of public
health in the United States.
I understand that there's some conflicting ideas around there how to do it, but I
will say I have been very impressed by at least the conviction that the goal
is the same, and that truly is to keep America as healthy as
possible. The NCI, I just want to repeat, though,
is pretty much immune to ideas about how to do that, and we
have been left largely on our own to develop how we want
to
approach better control and reduction of suffering from cancer.
Now, how you guys can communicate this.
This is another place where I think I would resist trying to tell you how to
do it too much, partly because I'm really not supposed to.
My job is to... I can educate Congress, and I'm happy to educate
support groups as well, or interest groups.
Very happy to participate in all of that.
But I would also say I think the
advocacy groups have been doing a great job.
I'm six months into this job, and I wouldn't presume to tell people who
probably know their jobs better than I do how they can go about it.
I would say I'm very open to discussions.
But I would say they're doing their jobs pretty well, and I'd
let them go at it.
Thanks.
Maybe I'll take one from the audience.
How long do you think it will take us to dig out of the damage that's inflicted on
cancer research in 2025, along the line of what we just talked
about?
So
that's difficult to answer without trying to
enunciate exactly what the damage is.
So part of the damage is, as I tried to acknowledge, is I think is reduced
number of
grants overall due to multi-year funding.
I, again, want to come back to the fact that we are already actually realizing
benefits of the multi-year funding in 2025 because
we don't have to pay the out years, the years two, three, four, five of the grants
that we paid for fully in 2025. Now, the
reason why there was a smaller number of grants then was because there was a sudden
increase from closer to zero to something like
50% over the latter half of the year when we were doing our funding.Those
rapid shifts make it challenging to keep the numbers of grants up.
However, once you achieve a stable level of multi-year funding, it's not
an ongoing problem because you continue to have these benefits from
the ones that you do multi-year fund. You don't have to pay the out-years.
So if you're a steady state, whether it's 0%,
50%, or 100%, you get to fund the same number of grants.
So we're already seeing that in
fiscal year 2026. The way we have it budgeted, we no longer have a pay
line, but I would expect a success rate of
something like 11% for R01s, for instance, in fiscal year
2026. And I would expect us to be paying out roughly the same
number of grants that we paid out through new grants in 2023
and 2024. So to that extent, the sort of financial effects,
I think, will be largely healed. I would say that part of what
is referred to as the damage was on the basis of
misinformation and incorrect information about how some of these decisions were
made and about what the result of the decisions were.
Yes, there was an initial proposal to cut the budget of the
NCI by 40% or 37%, but that didn't come to
fruition. What actually happened is we got a budget that was slightly higher than
it was in fiscal year 2024. So
I'd urge people who
are reading a lot of doom and gloom,
continue to keep an eye on the funding we get out the door.
I'm quite confident we're going to spend out our entire budget this
year for a record allocation to the extramural
community. And if we do do that, I would also
urge you to reflect on the sources of information and ask yourself if you
think you're getting the most
accurate information from those sources.
Because one of the things I've learned is there's times when I know some
things that are not publicly available,
and there are people willing to very confidently state things that aren't
true in the absence of really good information.
So I'd say keep an eye on the actual information you get a handle on,
and
I think you may find that the damage is going to be largely healed, and
we'll be back to what our baseline was.
Now, I also want to remind you that baseline might not be
what you wished it was. So for many years, we've been suffering,
if you will, from pay lines in
somewhere between 10 and 20. I don't see that changing at any time in the
future. Part of that is because our funding is
stable or increasing at sort of a linear rate, whereas the number of
trainees and investigators who are applying for grants is going
up more than linear, sometimes more like exponential.
If you consider those two things, there's no way that we're going to be able to
keep up with actual funding the same numbers over time.
So we will continue to be in a situation where nine out of 10 grants are not going
to get funded, but that's not new. That's what I'd call climate rather than
weather.
The way to address that, yes, you could increase NCI funding, and that would help
with that. But our job is not to advocate for that, but to be good
stewards and to do the best we can with the funding that we do get.
All right. I'm going to start being the good cop here and ask the fun questions.
At least-
Does that make her the bad cop?
Yes. Yes, it does.
Thanks.
No, I want to just maybe go
kind of another layer in your thinking on
sort of scientific priority.
So I think, the use of human tissue for discovery and potentially
therapeutic diagnostic purposes,
understand that conversation's going to happen.
We'll see where that leads to in terms of
projects/initiatives, vaccines you spoke about.
Is there another technology,
really kind of broadly anywhere in the research-enabling technology
that you think we've sort of under attended to or a little behind schedule on
where we need to see more integration into our
research approaches?
Boy, I think I'm just going to use that as an opportunity to talk a little bit more
about functional precision medicine, which is the use of human tissues in many
different ways.
I think it might be helpful to cover the history of this because it's a
very commonsensical idea. We use it in microbiology.
Any doctors out there, we use it in microbiology every day.
The gold standard for determining how you're going to treat a particular blood
infection or urinary tract infection is you take the actual
organism causing the disease, you grow it, and then you expose
it to all the drugs, and you see the ones that work best, and
that's
the drug that is the ideal drug to use to cure that type of bacterial
infection. So it's a very simple, powerful, and effective
idea. So of course, it actually was tested in cancer biology
in a series of experiments that probably reached their zenith roughly in the
late 1990s.
A few things happened then. One is that it didn't progress much further.
The technologies were limited then.
But in addition to the technologies being limited, the number of drugs that you
could test then was pretty limited.
So very often you might be testing whether something was platinum sensitive or
not. Well, if it wasn't, then there wasn't really an exciting alternative to
provide the patient.
Another thing that happened, of course, was the fantastic
demonstration of the utility of genetic alterations to direct
therapy when Imatinib was approved for CML, and shortly on its
heels, the ability to sequence the entire human genome.
And now we've sequenced, I don't know, hundreds of thousands of human genomes since
then. And so that displaced, and it's completely
understandable, there had to be a time where the field of cancer biology
explored the extent of genomic precision predictive biomarkers.
And they helped a lot. I think we can point to work in
melanoma. We can look at work in lung cancer.
We can look at work across many different diseases where mutations help
direct new, active, relatively non-toxic
drugs.But I would say the effect of those drugs generally
wasn't as impressive as it was for CML and imatinib,
where you essentially took a
disease likely to be fatal and turned it into
people who had a normal life expectancy as long as they kept taking this drug.
Also, I think we did some genomic studies that demonstrated that it's the
minority of cancer patients who can benefit from purely genomic
approaches, and new biomarker approaches were required.
I and some others like me started to turn to simple-- I'm a cell
biologist, and cell biology experiments and ask the question, "Hey, why don't
we just put drugs on cells and see if they work?" And in fact, that first occurred
to me when I was trying to figure out how venetoclax worked.
And in fact, the postdoc who did those experiments is staring at me right now.
But when I found that was so effective, I asked myself, "Why don't we do this all
the time?" And I started to look around the world, and it turned out there were
people doing this around the world, but they were sort of all in their own little
groups, and so I tried to unite them a little bit.
The point is that I think that now we have vastly better
cell biology technologies. We have vastly better single-cell analysis
technologies. They can be aided by AI and automated imaging.
We also have way more drugs, making every aspect of what I call
functional precision medicine more exciting and more powerful.
I think what stands in our way are some logistical issues,
such as handling of tumor cells.
One of the first things we do when we biopsy a tumor is we kill all the cells by
putting it in formalin. That's no good for the sort of approach we have.
We need to do a better job of demonstrating that functional precision medicine
works
so that then the tissues that we need will become more easily available.
That's part of what I want to do at the NCI, is jumpstart that program.
Well, that touches on a question that...
You just, using the term cancer cells,
someone in the audience was
kind of posing the question of whether there are ways to preserve
other cells in the microenvironment in a way, using the same
approach so that one doesn't lose
information regarding the role that cells in the microenvironment can play in
terms of therapeutic resistance and, I suppose, even to a degree, sensitivity.
Right. There's many different approaches
to these assays. The approach like my laboratory took, which doesn't need to be the
defining approach, is we just take all the cells and put them in.
So we do include those microenvironmental cells.
But
one thing I really want to make clear is there are discovery
avenues with these sorts of approaches, but they may not use the
identical techniques as actual clinical assays.
Mm-hmm.
So in a discovery approach, maybe you're going to be much more concerned
about perfect recapitulation of the in vivo environment, maybe the
3D shapes, sizes, that sort of thing.
However, if you're making a clinical assay, you want to make it as complex as
necessary and not one iota more complex.
So, you need to worry about concerns of cost,
reproducibility, and rapidity if you're making a clinical assay.
So
my approach to this problem is to try very simple assays first and
see if they perform the gold standard function of actually predicting
the in vivo response, and if they do,
well, then you can reflect on whether they include or don't include
the microenvironmental
elements. But if you're getting accurate answers and they don't include those
elements, it proves like for this narrow function, you don't need that.
And that's not to say they're not important for biology, it's just that you're
looking at a very narrow engineering problem rather than
a discovery problem when you're trying to make a patient clinical predictive
biomarker.
I'm going to change the topic. I'm going to ask you about the workforce.
We have a lot of early career investigators that
are at the meeting, and we also understand over the
last couple of years,
there are many... High percentage of them are concerned about, for
example,
able to earn the first R01, get their tenure track.
Without the pay line, obviously, there is a concern how they're going to get an
R01. Many of them are thinking of leaving science.
Many of them are thinking of leaving US.
How can we recharge the
whole early career investigators, mid-career investigators, so
that they are able to continue to invest their energy and time
in science?
Okay. Let me address the technical issue of the Early Stage Investigator
Award. So in the past, when there was such a thing as a pay line,
many of you may know this, but let's say the pay line for the general public was
12%. Well, we might set a pay line at the NCI for early stage
investigators of 17 or 18%, so a grant that didn't
score quite as highly would still get over the funding line as long as they
qualified for being an early stage investigator.
So it's a good question. When the pay lines go away, how do we ensure that we are
still funding early stage investigators? Well, we're doing it by number.
That is, we looked at the numbers of early stage investigators that were
successful using these previous regimens, and in our budget, we have
budgeted to provide that same number of Early Stage Investigator Awards.
So in the past, with the exception of '20 to
'25, in the recent past, it's been in the sort of 100 to 120
range, and we're aiming for roughly 120 in fiscal year 2026.
So all we can do is fund the same number of awards as before.
And hopefully, that provides some reassurance, even if we can't tell you the exact
score you need to do it, because frankly, we don't know it.
That's not the way that we do things.
I would also say, I want to be careful that we don't equate
scientific success with getting an R01, or indeed,
scientific success with the pure pursuit
of an academic tenure track career.As I walked around here
and just being alive in the world of cancer research for the last decade,
there is a tremendous amount of very exciting, very productive, very worthwhile
research being performed in the biotech community or the pharma community
outside of academia.
The numbers don't work for every talented postdoc to get a tenure
track position. Once that might have worked, but the numbers don't work anymore.
I think many of us have
trained double-digit postdoctoral fellows for careers,
and you can just do the math in your head.
If every PI trains, let's say, 10
people for PI positions, and then they train 10 people for PI
positions, and then so forth, there's no way the
academic community will possibly have the capacity to
have all these people. So
I don't want to equate success with all of those people finding tenure
track academic positions.
I would also say, and I think I'll close my answer with this, I view
the support of the extramural early stage investor
community as a partnership with cancer centers and
with universities. And I would hope that, I've tried to
explain in my remarks here and otherwise, that there are political
considerations that sometimes cause the interruption of grant funding, such
as you saw the shutdown of the government at the end of 2025.
It's incumbent upon, I believe, and in those cases, like at the
NCI, our hands are completely tied.
We are not legally allowed to do anything.
I would hope, and I think this has largely been the case in cases of disruptions
like that and other disruptions that we have no control over,
cancer centers would step in and support their early stage investigators with their
own resources, because there is no alternative if the NCI is
shut off. I want to say that I don't expect there to be a long-term
downturn shutoff of NCI funding, but these episodic phenomena
can occur, as we've seen in 2025. We will certainly do the best to
buffer it, but there's also a role for the cancer centers and academic centers
to buffer that.
Maybe just follow quickly in terms of, and earlier on in the pipeline,
what the NCI is thinking in terms of undergraduate
students, high school students, to really attract them to the field
of cancer research.
So I'd say the main thing is I hear
people ask me questions that lead me to believe that there's some question about
whether we're stopping training programs, T32s, those sorts of things. We're not.
We
continue with our same commitment that we've had.
We're not changing anything in that regard.
We continue with programs like the YES program, like the CURE
program, and the I-CURE program to encourage young people to
get their first experience in laboratory-based science.
And really, the main message I would say is nothing has changed.
So,
at this meeting, I've been beginning to socialize sort of
my nascent concepts for what might become my
presidential initiative, and it ultimately touches on cancer
disparities and
forming a bit more of a
team science approach of sorts. More to come on that topic.
But one of our audience members
raises a question about cancer disparities research.
Are you
getting a sense or hearing anything from outside of
NCI that you think would impede the NCI's ability to continue to
support cancer disparities research?
No, I think you can look at our portfolio and see that we continue to fund cancer
disparities research.
I'll just reiterate something I presented, which is that these disparities
actually include geographical disparities.
Mm-hmm.
So
I described that program, P-S-E-D-I, PSEDI, or the prevention
screening
program.
We're going to pilot that in a region
that is relatively poor in America.
It's sort of a swath from Southern Appalachia down through Mississippi, east
of the Mississippi River. That will include five states there, as well
as scattered counties where we have identified to have the
greatest cancer-related mortality.
So we're trying to go bring these forward directly
to the people who need the most, the people who've had, for whatever reason,
the least use of screening technologies and prevention technologies that
could help them. Just for information, we're going to coordinate this with other
institutes at the NIH to screen, at the same time,
other diseases that aren't strictly cancer, metabolic disease, heart disease,
diabetes, kidney disease, that sort of thing.
But it's a good opportunity to do all these sorts of things together.
Mm-hmm.
As I'm a clinical trialist, I'm going to ask you about clinical trials.
You mentioned earlier that
we're not as globally competitive as we were, and
obviously many parts of Asia-Pacific are catching up,
maybe exceeding in some areas. And you also mentioned about efficiency,
how to increase efficiency, not just at the NCI level,
but at the local level. Can you elaborate further on that?
Yeah. I think
this is not all bad. I think if our goal
is to do our best for cancer patients, I think we can take this as a
wake-up call, but we also have a book we can learn from
in the shape of the Australian clinical trial
regimen.
And they're very open with what they're doing.
The combination of things, including
sort of central
contracting language that can be shared, that is embraced by both
biotech and the academic cancer center communities there, so that
the time of contracting that is sometimes so onerous and so painful in
this country is cut way down because people already largely know what the
contract's going to look like. There's also a
process by which local IRBs can actually approve
without government intervention.
They can approveThe initial first in human trials,
especially for cancer. There's also a sharing of
IRBs and a greater use of centralized IRBs in
Australia. All these things speed things tremendously, but there's also just a
focus, and I've also found this in talking to cancer centers here in the United
States, is one of the things you need to make it better is first admit you
have a problem and devote the resources and the attention to fixing that
problem. Realize that it's taking too long to
activate your trials.
Realize that there's too many processes that are done in
series that could be done in parallel and make things much
faster. There's also regulation that I think could be improved, and I'll tell you
the FDA is very aware of this, and I think you will see, you've already
started to see, and you will continue to see, I think, over the next year, some
initiatives being rolled out by the FDA, while we cannot duplicate the
Australian approach to get closer and to imitate some of the things they've done
that has made them faster.
Yeah. So maybe just sticking with clinical research,
in the intramural program,
I've heard you mention in other venues,
some interest in maybe sort of
reinvesting and deploying intramural resources like the clinical center,
in a way that maybe haven't been considered
in recent years. So just, can you give us a sense of kind of what
your thinking is in terms of sort of best use of the Bethesda campus as it pertains
to driving clinical research?
Right. I think,
the Bethesda campus
really should be a jewel for clinical
investigation. You have in close proximity a really top
clinical center, that's what we call it, Central Hospital,
and you have a really top research institute.
What I see to make the most out of that is really focusing
on collaboration between the two in a way that I think we don't quite have in
place right now. We have excellent people at both institutions, and I think
they need to knit together a little bit better,
in a very intentional way.
We have had, for a variety of reasons, some key leadership
positions absent,
or just in the acting state over last few years,
including the head of our biggest clinical department, CCR, as
well as,
we're lacking a final and permanent CEO for the clinical
center. I think those vacancies will be
filled in the next couple of months, and that's going to help
tremendously for the NCI, which is the biggest user of
the intramural clinical center. It's going to help us tremendously at
actually getting this moving again.
I should say we're all very aware
of the problems with not using the clinical center to its capacity.
It's already getting a little bit better.
I'd also say that Jay Bhattacharya, the NIH director, is
absolutely convicted that we need to have a strong
clinical center and that we need this to be one of the
jewels
for the whole NIH, not just for the NCI.
Let me bring it back to our patients.
Everything we do from bench to bedside is really to
benefit our patients. So obviously
they are worried about cancer research, given what has been
happening in the last few years. What's your message to our
patients? How can we bring exciting drugs to
them faster? How can we assure them the science is going on as
strong as ever?
I think I started with a description.
I do think we need to continue to reach out to patients.
I think part of it is this program, the EURNCI program that we're going to employ.
I also want to explore, and we're doing this in our communications
office, ways that we can reach patients where they are.
I like the idea of maybe like an NCI app, something on the phone that would
be useful that would connect patients with cancer, something that'd be very easily
accessible,
that would provide the tools they need to perhaps navigate a
cancer diagnosis of their own or of a loved one.
These are just very early ideas, but I think we certainly have the technology
to do that, and we can be more useful to them.
Also, part of, I think, a challenge of
2025 was a lot of these things happened in the absence of a
permanent director.
There's nothing magical about me, but I am a permanent director now, and I
have the ability to communicate, I think, a little more broadly,
and a little more directly about both political and
scientific issues at the NCI, and I plan to
continue to do that. And,
hopefully, it won't be a matter of
dropping bombshell after bombshell.
I'm really trying to convey an idea that the NCI has
not changed
its commitment to research, its commitment to clinical care has not changed,
and we're continuing to be there with the same mission,
which is to reduce suffering of exactly those patients that you're talking about.
Okay.
Yeah. Just maybe, a question, longstanding
area that the private sector tends to not invest
in,
is in prevention. And so early screening you've spoken to,
and I think obviously that's a component of
how to get ahead of cancer diagnosis in the first place.
But, in terms of prevention, research that ultimately could lead to
sort of prevention approaches,
recognizing that some of this question is not necessarily strictly
cancer research, but could be other aspects of human
health. Just kind of wondering what your current
thinking is in terms of what are initiatives,
directions, just approaches that in the prevention
area specifically that you think are a priority?
Phil Castle, who's head of our division of cancer prevention,
told me the best cancer is the one you never get.
Mm-hmm.
And that's the principle that really drives cancer prevention.
I think that
we have to stay on top of tobacco, particularly combustible
tobacco. In my
opinion, I don't think there's any other
preventable exposure that is in the same order of magnitude of risk that is
tobacco. So we can't let our attention on that flag.
If you look at the next ones, they're also important,
but they're not going to be as important as tobacco from an epidemiological
perspective. But these would include obesity and probably
alcohol use.
In addition to that,
there are other environmental exposures that
I think we just don't know enough about,
that may be contributing to cancer.
But I do think we need to
get better, and this is something I want to work on.
We need to get better about communicating this to America.
Mm-hmm.
Right now, I think we have, certainly here in the state of California, I
just noticed on my way over here, walking by the garage, big sign that the
garage is carcinogenic. Okay? I don't know how helpful that is
because people still need parking garages,
and I'm not sure that that really conveys the message that needs to be
conveyed, and that is that there are different levels of
carcinogenicity. Some things are major
contributors to carcinogenesis, and some,
perhaps in a large series with a very small effect size, can also
be said to do that. But those are very different concepts, and I
think we have to get better at communicating this to people, because I think the
general public views all materials as a binary.
They either cause cancer or they don't cause cancer.
Mm-hmm.
And we need to pay most of the attention on the things that are biggest
contributors of causing cancer and maybe not spend as much
attention on the ones that are very minor contributors.
So part of that involves a way to educate the public on
the basics of effect size, and maybe,
not only relative risk, but absolute risk.
If I knew that drinking beer doubled my risk
of some incredibly rare synovial sarcoma,
I would probably continue to drink beer, because if my risk of getting a synovial
sarcoma is doubled, it still is not that high because it's a very rare
disease.
And I think without providing people with all the tools to understand this, and I
think we can, we're not really doing our job at effectively
communicating useful prevention strategies that can also
be incorporated into a normal lifestyle.
If everything causes cancer, people just turn it off.
Mm-hmm.
I think I'll ask close to my last question, as we are going
down on the clock.
I think there has been a decrease in trust in science.
I think there is no doubt about that.
How, as scientists, we can help the NCI to reverse that
distrust?
I think that's a great point. I think that is something the NCI can do, because I
think we are in a unique position of public trust that maybe isn't
shared by other institutes or other organs of
government. The way I
plan to do it is, for starters, I think we need to be, as a public health
community, I think we need to be universally more respectful.
If someone brings up an idea about a drug, about an
antihelminth, that they have read or
heard cures cancer,
the answer shouldn't be, "You ignorant rube, how hilarious that
you think this is the case." Instead, we, as scientists, should be
prepared to calmly lay out the data
that might support or refute the idea that this particular drug
that we might consider absurd does or does not contribute to
the treatment of cancer. If we can't do that, we're not doing our job,
and we're missing an opportunity to connect as a member of the
public that probably needs it the most.
So I think a lot of this really starts with just mutual respect, and
understand that when people are coming to you with funny ideas, they're
often desperate people that are suffering greatly because of their own
personal or
medical problems or medical problems of a loved one.
Well, I think I'll give you the chair's prerogative of having asked the last
question.
Well, I want to thank Dr. Lotai for being with us, and thank you for all the
questions that you have submitted.
Yeah.
And, I think this has been very helpful for understand some of the
questions we have in our mind, and thank you for providing this address to
us during the annual meeting. Thank you.
And I also just want to thank the ACR.
It's been a very valuable opportunity for me at this whole meeting
to engage with the cancer community in a way I haven't been able to do so far as
director, and it's been very valued to me, and I want to thank the ACR for that.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you so much.